[Musique]
rendre rock ville texane de 120 mille
habitants située à une trentaine de
kilomètres de la capitale
austin est mondialement connue pour deux
raisons d'abord ses beignes format géant
pour cabaye la famille et sa nouvelle
venait mairie jennings mg comme tout le
monde l'appelle 42 ans ex pilote
d'hélicoptère blessés au combat en
afghanistan décoré plusieurs fois est
devenue une candidate vedette pour les
démocrates à la chambre des
représentants
cette vidéo qui racontent toutes les
portes qu'elle a dû ouvrir ou défoncées
dans sa vie a été visionné près de 3
millions de fois l'ancien militaire est
nouvelle en politique elle cherche à
déloger un adversaire en place depuis 16
ans dans un bastion républicain
légendaire mais au delà de sa vidéo
devenue virale et de son passé militaire
elle livre message qui tranche avec le
programme république est elle est en
faveur de la légalisation du cannabis du
contrôle des armes à feu de l'accueil
des réfugiés et de la lutte aux
changements climatiques
parmi ses partisans
des vétérans comme le colonel à la
retraite michael foster
le sénateur ted cloud êtes aussi en
campagne pour sa réélection
le représentant john carter et lui se
retrouve au même meeting privé dans un
quartier de retraités pour carter
l'essentiel c'est que rien ne change kim
jong il
ancien juge membres du mouvement radical
tea party élu au congrès sans
interruption depuis 2002 john carter
fait face à une réalité nouvelle avant
il n'avait jamais été vraiment menacer
son adversaire a recueilli trois fois
plus d'argent que lui grâce entre autres
à sa vidéo à ses côtés le sénateur ted
blues en est à son 30e grand
rassemblement en six semaines de
campagne
il présente avec fierté son bilan sous
la présidence de dans notre homme lui
aussi est sérieusement menacé par un
candidat démocrate devenu très populaire
beto en rock les aînés du texas ne
semble pas tout à fait prêt à changer
d'allégeance et ça inclut une partie des
vétérans du jeu
au texas tribune au journal le web de la
capitale
austin on observe avec grand intérêt le
déroulement de cette campagne pas comme
les autres cette fois les bleus
démocrate concentrés dans la région
d'austin pourrait gagner du terrain sur
les rouges républicaine selon plusieurs
sondages
une forte majorité de femmes dans les
banlieues américaines s'apprêtent à
sanctionner l'administration trump peut
être même ici à bolton localité très
conservatrice la candidate démocrate mg
rigueur a beau avoir dépensé des
millions de dollars en publicité
elle semble plus connu sur le web que
dans certains coins de son propre
district un autre groupe d'électeurs
pourraient faire pencher la balance
beaucoup de jeunes sont choqués par les
politiques et les comportements du
président 3 certains réagissent en
s'impliquant avec les démocrates
[Musique]
cette fois les démocrates ont déployé
des efforts considérables pour recruter
des vétérans qui sont au centre de leur
stratégie pour tenter de reprendre le
contrôle du congrès parmi eux plusieurs
femmes qui ont combattu notamment en
irak et en afghanistan
les démocrates veulent changer leur
image d'intellectuel de gauche et ils
veulent stimuler le vote qui dépassait à
peine 50 % aux dernières élections
ils ont un message pour les canadiens
[Applaudissements]